e aí o bicho jornal todo mundo você e eu
sou muito pouco estou usando a mesma
roupa do ano passado não estamos
gravando mesmo dia deu mais um vídeo
gira experiências a todas as pessoas que
pediram então se você for nas pessoas
que estavam esperando se você gosta 12
você admira meu trabalho
você quer que eu continue por favor
clique aqui e gostei explicou não gostei
e me ajuda muito para [ __ ] do mundo
inter tem que ser uma simples piada já
expliquei e vou explicar de novo você
chega na bola no canto muita gente falar
ah moleque ele fala errado ou no google
só fala merda vai dormir fé é teu pai
assim idiota mesmo anos é o que sabem
escrever só pode ser do nordeste mas o
nosso carro
isso aqui não é falar errado é cultura é
de cada lugar cada lugar tem o seu modo
de falar assim como um super forte e que
a gente tinha a ver nada tinha uma coisa
de lata outro de lá errado escreveu te a
redação é muito mais errado escreveu um
treino a rede social é a descrever um
alguma coisa assim
tem uma coisa - eu acho que não é da
cultura de lá as pessoas lá vão entender
é que não é que eu queira escrever
machucar escrever heitor aí aqui não
aqui a coisa aqui não é errado então já
tá explicado e que faz bonita cheia do
piauí e ensina vocês alguns dias para
conhecer o nordeste no meio da roupa
o nordeste em tudo bom
vai lá e converse na língua deles vamos
a primeira gira vólei sabor da mulher o
que é moléstia moléstia quando você quer
dar a impressão maior que você está
falando você quer dar um impacto maior
que você está falando com o cartoon sei
que isso aí é quando está consciente mas
você está com muitas cenas pacato
conseguida no leste também podem a
cirurgia
a rainha que é prévia prega para quem é
de fora porque tem muitas gírias que
elas parecem ser usada só em lugar mas
não só é usado em muitos outros lugares
agora eu acho que prega o apoio
exclusivo do nordeste pra quem não sabe
a que prédio você sabe que anos com
certeza vou tentar explicar da maneira
mais educada possível no ânus existem
outras deixam as coisas que parte da que
faz o seu anos tenha ela a felicidade
com sua sanfona a prega é o que faz com
que aquilo fica fechado e fico
contraíram se o seu ânus e assim marcar
na época você tem pra ir ao show do
neymar é que você não tem mais pressa
pegar por aí então voltava foi se apega
a rainha é porque já era igual à praia
do cabo já foi mal e tomou perder a
estreia pode até o dia 8 falei que eu
falei é é tem algumas pessoas de fora
que não entende a maioria da sua equipe
a gente fala porque quente a gente meio
que inventa algumas coisas por exemplo
armaria na muita gente demora para
entender o que é a mariah na a maria na
pessoa num sair nunca falei é s
quando acontece alguma coisa
surpreendente
valeu no céu é procópio valeu do céu nem
quebrou a porta ao ego do céu e pegar a
fé é a lembrança do céu foi essa praga
rainha alegre do samu bateu o carro
soltando mais e melhor se prega olha
para fugirem
a senhora não paga com medo de perder a
perna resolvida a pé e não sabe é tipo
qualquer tipo de pulo violenta pessoal
rodadas você dá uma voadora em um café
se o boi é é água no poço está dando o
sangue a pé
você forma um movimento pulando essa tá
bancando a pé tocando até isso é tudo
que envolve o túnel por um pouco no
chute alguma coisa sim é a falar tudo
isso aqui na pele esse é um campeonato
larga na pele a campanha pé marina então
você prometeu final do vídeo é fazer uma
história com todas as vezes que eu falar
aqui então vamos lá
a apae fulano hoje está no leste velho
tá novo casa chegou no candá papel para
pô não em cada um pega pega correcta
médica de que as pregas foi embora o bei
e no artigo 1 chegando fábio fassini
abaixo das participadas sábado para o
flamengo perdeu a fé é um problema dela
nozoe à noite eu já cheguei lá e lê
quando chegar nos vai dela depende o
magazine luiza mmartan noite a beber
você
o pl vida humana escrito to me machucou
muito e pude mario de hollywood parece k
amor parece um letreiro e ainda é meu
perfil eu não fosse assim não repetiu
não vai perceber
[Música]
é isso aí é então muito obrigado você
acha desse vídeo você já sabe que tem
que fazer é quando você tem que mostrar
fico muito feliz que cuba é com mais
vontade de gravar vídeo porque sabe que
as pessoas gostaram que eu fiz é o que
me move italianos sabem que as pessoas
daqui nada do meu trabalho é muito boa
pra que eu continue fazendo e eu quero
que você comente aqui em baixo ao
rangers que tem na sociedade que talvez
eu posso não saber para usar em outros
vídeos aí e é isso aí e pra você fala
colega de novo na equipe entrou só
escrever que inscreva se aqui quando
devem não só vai saber ele tem os seus
caminhos legais aqui ó caminho
você pode comprar nesse site aqui ó é da
hora tem muitos os caminhos legais e é
isso aí muito obrigado a falar